字幕: Yuri Ueda
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
僕は陶芸の街 愛知県の瀬戸市で育ちました
近所は陶器工場だらけで
ロクロや絵付 そして窯焼きを目にするのが
当たり前の生活を送ってたんです
もう幼い頃から
粘土を遊び道具にしていました
思い描いたモノをカタチにして驚かすことが
自然と身についていた僕は
デザイナーを目指しました
個人デザイナーとして
起業して15年が経った頃
僕は自分の原点でもある故郷の「せともの」を
題材に作品を作ることを 決意したんです
しかし 友達が少なく
これまで自分のデザイナーとしての活動を
全くPRしてこなかった僕は
作ってもらうためのツテも
説得要素も全く持ってませんでした
何十件も窯元にお願いしたんですが
全然相手にされなかったんですね
自分の不甲斐なさを故郷で思い知らされました
でも 僕は同時にこうも思ったんです
「だからこそ 今 ここからやり直そう」と
そう決意して 立ち直った僕は
ようやく作ってくれる窯元と
巡り会うことができたんです
忘れられないのが
「おいおいおい 窯から出したらさ
もうなんか宝石みたいにキラキラした
すんごいのが出来てんだよ」と
陶器の職人さんが驚いていたことです
これです
いや本当に僕も驚いてしまいまして
本当ちょっとすごいと思いませんか？
親鳥が卵を抱きしめて守る
その姿がまた卵に見える
「巡る命」をテーマにデザインしました
「ここが自分の原点だ」
という思いも込めています
幼い頃 粘土で遊んでいた僕と
デザイナーである現在の僕との
コラボレーションとも言えるのです
この作品を生み出してから
新しい道が開けていきました
シンガポールの五つ星ホテルで認められて
地元の新聞やテレビに取り上げられたんです
これまで 依頼を受けて
デザイナーをさせてもらってきた僕には
もう 起こり得ない未経験なことでした
思い描いたものをカタチにして発表したら
これだけたくさんの人たちから
関心を得られたと感じた僕は
これからも作品を作り続けようと
決意したんです
次は琉球ガラスを作りたいと
沖縄の工房を訪れていましたが
相変わらず断られ続けていました
そんな中 僕は 肺ガンを告知されたんです
検査入院の夜に 僕は暗闇に映る
心電図をぼうっと見てました
「あぁあれが自分の命か
あの形が命のカタチっていうのかな」
手術を一週間後に控えた日
僕は沖縄を訪れました
ようやく工房に入れてもらいました
一年かかってようやく入れてもらいました
ご年配の職人さんが 声をかけてくれました
「おー 今日はどうした」ってね
僕は「これを作りたいんだ」と
デザイン画を見せました
すると「うーん うーん
どうだろうね」と
姿を消してしまったんですね
しばらくすると
「ここ こういうこと こういう感じ
こういう感じ ここがもっとこうだ
でも もっとこうしたいよね」と
僕がデザインしたアイデアを模して
ガラスでちょっと作ってきてくれてたんですね
「水野さん やりましたね」と
これまでお相手してくれていた
部長さんが隣で微笑んでいました
その職人さんは 現代の名工に選ばれるほどの
すごい職人さんだったんです
その職人さんがトライしたくなった
ということが「作る」という合図だったんです
デザインと熱意が伝わったことに
僕は涙が溢れそうになりました
手術を終えた一ヶ月後
僕は再び沖縄を訪れました
そこには美しい琉球ガラスが
出来上がっていました
検査入院の夜に感じた
自分の命の波形をモチーフに
底面を強く波立たせて隆起させた
この命が沸き上がるような美しい琉球ガラス
この形を再現することが如何に大変だったか
そこには職人さんたちの
挑戦の痕跡がありました
デザインで職人さんの心を
動かすことができたこと
そしてその素晴らしい技術をお借りすることが
叶ったことに 僕は胸が満たされました
神様はきっとこれを作るために
僕をガンにしたんだと思いました
そして 次はここ
安城市の町工場との作品です
コロナショックで 近隣企業は
大ダメージを受けました
僕も同じなんですけどね
もし このまま世の中から
ものづくりが消えてしまったら
デザインもいらなくなってしまう
だったら デザインでものづくりの火を
絶やさないようにしようと考えたんです
最初はパイプ加工会社と
パイプ椅子を作りました
これなんですけどね
パイプ加工技術を
PRするためだけにデザインした
この硬くて柔らかくて そして
この無限ループを描くようなね
美しいこの造形には
起死回生の思いを込めてるんです
板金加工会社とは
「宅配ボックス」を生み出しました
コロナで宅配ボックスが
注目されてましたからね
で僕がデザインしたものがこれです
僕はこれを自宅で使ってます
設置した当初はドライバーさんに
「これ何ですか？」とよく尋ねられたんですが
「あややや 宅配ボックスですよ
ほら ここを開くじゃないですか」
とこう説明をいたしますと
「えーっ」という反応が毎度返ってきましたが
今ではもう当たり前のように荷物届きます
そして 次はプレス加工会社との作品です
自社で開発した
足で扉を開く感染予防ツールの
コピー商品が出回ってて悔しいと
僕に相談があったんです
「だったら もうパクれないぐらい
ぶっちぎりなもん作ってやろう」と
デザインしたのがこれです
光の粒子を立体で表現した
型押し造形としては
相当チャレンジングなこのデザインには
「偽物なんかには負けねえぞ」
という思いが込められています
この安城の３つの作品ではどれも
「いや こんなデザイン見たことないな
というか そもそもこれ作れるのかな」
という反応ばかりでした
「でも いや でもなんか作りたいな
今だからやっぱり挑戦してみたいな
うん作る」
と言ってくれたんですね
こうして職人さんたちは
見事挑戦することを重ねてくれまして
この素晴らしい作品たちが
生み出されることになりました
そして去年
僕は新たな作品を生み出しました
金型です
金型は溶かし込んだり
曲げたり押したり 凹ませたり
材料を形にするための道具です
例えば たい焼きとか
生地を鯛の形にするのは金型ですよね
型はものづくりの原点
故郷の瀬戸物 琉球ガラス
そして町工場との作品たちを経て
次に生み出したいものが明確になったんです
それは「ものづくり」そのものです
そこで僕は 富山県の高岡市に目をつけました
高岡市は 金属を型に溶かして流し込んで作る
鋳物の街で有名ですが
同時に金型職人さんの街でもあるんです
これまでの作品作りを通して得たのは
作る人が挑戦したくなるデザインを
持ち込むことの重要性でした
作る人がまず おっと驚くことで
良い作品作りへの第一歩に
つながるということですね
初めての打ち合わせの日
いや こんな発想なかったなぁと
まんまと驚いてくれた金型職人さんたち
いや これをどうやって作ったらいいんだ
しかしもぅ あ でもこうすれば
うーん あ でもな と
険しい顔してたんですけども
どこかわくわくしているようにも感じました
このプロジェクトに挑戦させたい
デザイナーを参加させるために
彼女の所属している会社を口説きました
かなり結構苦労しましたんですが
この作品作りの持つ意義を理解いただけて
協賛までしてくれることになりました
こうしてできあがった金型がこれです
オブジェのようであり 和菓子のようでもある
そして 家紋のようでもあります
これで出来上がるものがこれです
チョコレート
閉じても開いても美しい
そして出来上がるのがチョコレートという
もうびっくり箱のような金型です
この金型には ものづくりは華のある仕事
花形職業なんだ という想いを込めてるんです
この手のひらに収まる小さな金型には
たくさんの人たちの
挑戦と情熱がこもってるんです
職人の技術がここに結晶してるんですね
ホワイトチョコレートのデザインは
口説いた企業のデザイナーに
挑戦してもらいました
普段の仕事ではまずすることがない
かわいらしいデザインに挑戦することで
すごく苦労していたような顔はしていましたが
見事成し遂げたことで
彼女の自信にもつながったはずです
そして なぜ
チョコレートを作る金型にしたのか
それは「お なんだこれ 面白そう
作ってみたい」と興味を引くためです
僕が幼い頃 身近にあった粘土で遊んで
それがデザイナーを志す
きっかけになったように
楽しみながらものづくりに
触れてもらって興味を引きたい
そのために生み出した金型なんです
さて皆さん デザイナーって何でしょうか
僕はこの作品作りを通して
デザイナーの役割を示すことができました
これを作ることができたなら
何かすごいことを起きるんじゃないか
と思わせる 一歩先行く
挑戦したくなるデザインで
関わる人たちの心を震わせることこそが
デザイナーの役割なんです
驚くものを僕がデザインして
共に一緒に作り上げていく
少し先の未来を見せて
共に解決に向かうことでー
お互いに認め合える そして
お互いに高め合い続けることができたんです
つらい時に「あぁなんで俺は
こんな挑戦続けてるんだろうか」
と自問自答することがありましたが
「カタチにして驚かすことが
お前の生きがいだろう」と
信念を持って うん そういうことで
貫き通すことができたんです
この強い思いから生み出した
デザインたちが
関わってくれた たくさんの人たちにとっても
価値のある挑戦であったら
うれしいんです
僕はこれからもデザイナーとして
驚かせ続けます
それが生きがいですから
ありがとうございました
（拍手）